well good morning afternoon / morning
Grafton and everybody thanks a lot for
sharing your beautiful sunny afternoon
in doors with no windows with me so
thank you and thank you Tom for that
nice introduction I also want to thank
the SCV p team Danielle Eli Dimitri all
you guys for doing Mike I only be doing
a great job helping me get the
preparation going for this talk as well
as just doing great things for us TVP
most of the talks in this series are by
entrepreneurs and I'm not and I'm not
going to tell you about my journey in my
vision and how I conquered all odds and
I never saw my family and I had a great
business I'm not going to do that I want
to talk about something else and that is
what academics do because while the
speakers that you often have by the way
have some seats have fun if y'all want
to come down what what most of our
speakers do and I think do very well is
they speak about 125 and sometimes the
10 companies they started and they know
those companies really well what
academics do is we study those companies
and I know probably hundreds of
companies sort of well so we're really
taking two different lenses there's the
deep dive of the individual entrepreneur
and there are people like me who are
voyeurs into the world of the
entrepreneur and so that's what I think
hopefully I will inspire some of you who
say maybe on entrepreneurship to be an
academic because it's a way better job I
think although I'm not as rich as Mark
Zuckerberg and never will be yeah come
on down if you want there's some spots
need some space okay so that's a little
bit of a start let me get good me eight
going on what the talks about i
straddled something likes you a little
bit serious this is a story about a
sergeant Edward Montoya who is in the
army US Army in Iraq about ten years ago
it's just before Christmas he's hanging
out in the tent with a bunch of his
buddies actually they're having dinner
and he's munching a little cheesecake
Anna the corner of his eye he sees this
flash and it's somebody dressed up in an
Iraqi security uniform setting himself
off and blowing the place up
Montoya is an army medic ducks under the
table he's okay gets out from under the
table nc's carnage what do you do when
you see hundreds of bodies that need you
some of whom were in pretty good shape
some of whom really or not some in the
middle what do you do and what I'm going
to argue today he's got a lot of the
same problem that janet yellen head of
the Federal Reserve crickets not an easy
job being a cricket and Mark Zuckerberg
particular as he starts facebook they
all have they all have the same problem
how do you cope with the complexity when
there's way too much to do and what I'm
going to argue today is all those people
and the crickets are using simple rules
by simple rules civil rules are
cognitive shortcut strategies the save
time and effort by focusing your
attention and simplifying how you think
that's basic definition what does that
mean in real life well super rules one
point oh there are three key features of
simple rules the first one is simple
rules are simple that means simple rules
there may be two three four or five
rules second simple rules are unique
your rules aren't necessarily my rules
and then finally simple rules relate to
something a defined activity not some
sort of general thing like be nice to
your mother although with Mother's Day
coming up I am into that may give you an
example what simple rules are Michael
Pollan Michael Pollan UC Berkeley
professor and author of botany of desire
Omnivore's Dilemma other great books has
some simple rules for eating eat real
food that your mother grandmother would
recognize eat mostly plants and not too
much all you have to do not too much
plants and things that are not processed
so you can eat blueberries kale
cantaloupe whatever you want that's
simple second idea is simple rules
depend on the person in the situation
Stanford football team vs. Michael
Pollan Michael Pollan middle-aged guy
he's got
his rules set for football team this
portion control is not really working
for them and there's no proteins not
really working for them rather what are
their rules their rules are more around
always be hydrated because they're busy
boys hard working their second rule is
eat breakfast because as students they
have a tendency to stay up late and get
up late and then rush the class and skip
breakfast so second rule skip practice
is always eat breakfast and the third
rule is eat things that you can pick
pluck or kill so again non-processed but
you can move past plants for those guys
so depends on who you are and then the
third idea is that simple rules i'll
give you one more example give you
IndieGoGo and Kickstarter to give you
get you more into the Entrepreneurship
realm here IndieGoGo both of them
crowdsourcing crowdfunding site
IndieGoGo is from again from Berkeley
actually and started with the mantra of
the internet is for everybody or
everybody deserves a rich uncle and
that's your crowdsourcing friends one of
the rules at IndieGoGo for projects you
can put anything on IndieGoGo if it's
legal you want to fund your root canal
go to indy gogo you want to fund your in
utero child go to indy gogo you want
your startup you want to be the Jamaican
bobsled team you go to indy gogo
IndieGoGo does not curate IndieGoGo and
since ted has an algorithm to pick their
favorites and it's based on effort which
they regard is very important and it's
based on what the popularity the project
is to the crowd contrast those rules
with Kickstarter Kickstarter starts out
actually in film they have is their
analogy we want to be like amazon amazon
starts in books we started films and
then add categories but not everything
can be on Kickstarter no root canals on
Kickstarter rather the way Kickstarter
works is your projects are curated
they're put into 13 buckets and about
twenty five percent of the projects
they're submitted don't ever appear on
Kickstarter and then how do they curate
in terms of what's the popular pics of
the staff the staff actually picks not
not an algorithm overall the point is to
ostensibly the same businesses using
fundamentally different rules the
android rules i'm indy gogo versus the
Apple rules of of Kickstarter open
system closed system and then finally
the idea is that simple rules relate to
a defined activity choosing the right
food or picking crowdfunding projects ok
that's that simple rules one point oh
how do you create simple rules where do
they come from determine your objective
keep it specific I want to be the number
one us solar residential company by
measured by revenue for example or I
want to lose 15 pounds find the
bottleneck what's the thing that's
really keeping you from what you're
doing what's really the thing that's the
sticking so for example a great one
right now 44 yahoo appears to be getting
better mobile apps but the real
bottleneck is getting great computer
scientists to believe in the Yahoo dream
and then you figure out the rules the
rules that you pull together from expert
advice may be charting your own behavior
may be asking your friends give you an
example the original Lean Startup we're
all Amundson those of you know who don't
know who were all this he is a self
season an arctic explorer he's the first
person actually his team is the first
team to reach the South Pole in about
nineteen twelve he raced against Robert
Scott so it was the Norwegians versus
the Brits Scott was the well-financed
startup Roy wolde was the lien and Mead
agile startup five or six people on skis
carrying as little as possible pivoting
as needed what's the bottleneck what's
is we know as goal as goal is get to the
South Pole first and hopefully alive
what's the bottom like what's what do
you really have to do if you want to be
that it turns about it turns out it's
all about the dogs because you got to
actually get there and it's about the
dogs because that's really your
transport that's carrying the food
that's carrying your stuff you can ski
but you you've got to get your stuff
there
and so what he did actually has come up
with some simple rules about handle how
to handle the dogs rest the dogs once an
hour go about 8 to 12 miles a day so the
dogs know about that's about how much a
good dog can do and always have a lead
skier in front of the dogs because those
kind of dogs like to be dominated and
they are in a situation where either the
dog dominates or the person dominates
and you want the person to dominate you
put them out front simple rules gets
into the South Pole by contrast Scott
well you just have it's too long a story
to tell you how how disorganized he was
okay creating the rules so the original
Lean Startup about a more contemporary
example this is a TZ the TC is actually
an Eastern European startup and their
business is around a cafeteria food for
what was happening in Eastern Europe is
actually Czechoslovakia what was
happening is a lot of big companies
quickly from the states like google and
Oracle and so on we're moving to Eastern
Europe for a variety of reasons and the
entrepreneurs is it easy recognize the
opportunity of serving high quality food
to to their clientele and essentially
being the cafeteria of these companies
so they start out and they hire these
great chefs and they start you know
getting business and people love their
food and all that but there's sort of a
basic problem is they're not making any
money and so the goal becomes how about
making money but what's the bottleneck
is it lousy chefs actually no they have
great chefs is that they can't get the
food not that it really it turns out the
problem is the menu all the chefs are
doing their own thing on the menu and
just making it whatever they want
regardless of the season they're just
creating cool food and so with the chefs
the entrepreneurs started actually few
simple rules of on the menu the menus
for the next week are set on Wednesdays
by noon everybody serves five dishes
everybody serves three dishes that we
know are popular because what was
happening before is the chef's we're
just creating new all the time now you
have to actually double down on the ones
people like and the next rule was and
there too there are two meals that are
common across all the cafeterias so you
can do your own thing on
me but you got to be the same with
everybody else on to within those rules
do we do what you want turns out they
not only got profitable they also
started actually building their revenue
and they doubled in size actually in
something like 18 months so they're
sober happily ever after story another
startup on creating rules so this is
another sexy topic of concrete are you
probably not thinking too much about
concrete these days but did you know
that concrete is the third largest
source of man-made co2 in the world so
it's actually a huge environmental issue
we're on concrete it also is a very high
cap per capita consumption of contra
beat so per capita we all use a lot of
concrete it's right up there with water
believe it or not and so the what the
guy supreme quest did was come up with a
process that made for concrete that
lowered the admissions in the production
of cement also was you need to use less
cement so that saved on it and then also
was less likely to crack so what's a
soft me had to replace it so it's kind
of an eco win-win-win going on but what
do we do this is these are mostly
technical guys so they go to Las Vegas
and people enjoy their product and they
get all these partners who want to
partner with them you know hey well well
you know we'll do your concrete well
what are they how do they pick what we
have all these partners so that becomes
their bottom like who are going to
partner with and they start thinking
they look over some of their their
evidence i heard they worked well with
think about it look at other people talk
and come up with a couple of simple
rules about who to partner with first
rule was around what's partner with
people that have a laser screen machine
that wasn't top-of-mind to me but it
turns out it is to them because that's a
signal that that partner cares about
quality and cares about innovation if
they have that machine they're into it
like we're into it the second rule was
around no duplicate partners so
everybody gets their own territory
another rule was around if you haven't
started using our product within three
months you're done is our partner and
then the final rule was around we had a
partner roughly every three months we
can't do it faster that because we can't
really absorb the organization
within that context they then basically
started selling their concrete around
the world okay example internet dating
rules this is my teaser slide so you're
not going to find out that okay some
rules three-point oh you mr. you
betrayed the simple story of just what
the rules are keep it simple few rules
unique rules to you on a process to
point o what's your objective what's the
bottleneck what are the rules now we're
going to go to three point o turns out
there's different types of rules what
does an academic it was pretty
interesting to me that there were
different types and that they're harder
and easier to learn and that they have
more or less implications for
performance so the geek and me love that
aspect of it the practical person than
me like the fact that some actually
matter more than others let me tell you
a little bit about them first of all
there's boundary rules boundary rule
says it turns out are pretty easy to
learn situations where you're deciding
yes or no like whether or not to give
bail or you've got a lot of alternatives
which one to choose group of people who
really need a boundary rule or burglars
as it turns out because you know there's
a lot of houses you can burgle but you
really don't want to get caught so what
is a good burglar do what's the simple
rule never burgle a house with a car in
front turns out that is extraordinarily
good rule for knowing whether or not
anybody's home moving on from burglars
how about the weinstein company the
weinstein company is the is a movie
company as i would think at least some
of you know that in the background there
that you can look at that is a that is
the imitation game the movie which is a
Weinstein Company movie if you're a
movie company you see a lot of scripts
there are a lot of would-be writers
sending you scripts sending you story
ideas how do you pick well turns out the
weinstein company picks has a couple
simple rules one of them is always have
flawed and sympathetic main characters
and the second is have a story that's
about a base
human condition so if you saw the
imitation game you know that Alan Turing
is a truly annoying jerk but you know
you like him don't you I mean you really
do you do kind of like the guy so he's a
flawed with sympathetic main character
and then he's dealing with homosexuality
which which then adds a sort of a social
problem on top of it that's that's the
top of mind for at least some people
another movie by them is still the
silver linings playbook again dealing
with mental illness the artist The
King's Speech dealing with difficulties
and you know talking obviously that's
sorry there there John Rowe flawed with
sympathetic main character serious
common human condition so what movie
wouldn't they do gone girl did you all
see gone girl talk about unlikable
characters very own they're they're not
they're not Einstein company characters
also the Birdman if you saw the Birdman
another movie one side would never do
too annoying those people are too
annoying okay other boundary rules this
is actually a startup company called
frontier dental and here the problem is
and I'm those who started comes I'm sure
knows you try selling your product and
you talked to 100 people and nobody
nobody wants your product or three
people want your product and it takes
forever and so that was what was having
this company weren't getting any
traction in a new cosmetic dentistry
project product they started analyzing
when they were successful they started
thinking about it more they tracking
their own experience and came up with a
couple simple rules one of which was
again 10 a pretty simple one was go to
Dennis that have a great website because
Dennis that has a great website is it is
a forward-thinking dentist and then the
second thing is avoid any dentist that
has more than more than four finance
charges in a year because you want a
forward-thinking dentist who also pays
his or her bills okay that's that's
boundary rules priority rules are about
okay you've got a lot of things you
could do but what are really the
priorities typically happens when you
don't have enough time or enough
resources friends down the street Google
have a pretty interesting rule you think
about their their bottleneck
particularly in the early days but even
now it's hiring great computer science
talent
you can check the resumes and you can
see you know right school right grades
you know that kind of thing but how do
you really pick beyond that and it turns
out that google favors people that other
Googlers have referred to to Google so
for example Toby refers Albert and are
more likely to hire Albert because I
trust Toby's judgment because we know
that Googlers wants work with other
smart Googlers and so that turns out to
be a tie-break when everything else
looks the same they're also how to rules
those are back easy boundary rules and
how to rules are the easy ones to learn
priority rules are a little harder how
to rule is easy guiding the basic steps
of executing a task how do you actually
do things example of Twitter of a how-to
rules uh I know some of you are in
business already some of you will be in
business some of you had summer jobs but
you can spend an endless amount of time
in business in meetings constantly going
to meetings stuff happening in meetings
kind of a never get anything done what
some of the executives that at Twitter
are now starting to do is a pretty
interesting couple of rules around
meetings no power points because you
just waste time all right figuring out
power points and you're not allowed to
cancel a meeting because everybody's
organize their calendars around it and
it's really screws everybody up if
somebody if people keep canceling or not
coming so no power point it takes way
too much time don't cancel because you
mess up everybody one of the ironies of
rules howto rules is that in fact highly
creative people are often using rules it
may not be your rules and they may be
creating their own sandbox but they
often are operating off rules good
example is the band The White Stripes
know if your white stripes fans but
white stripes and catch up on my notes
here why strides did their their album
the white blood cells which is one of
the sort of albums of the decades in the
2000s they did that album 18 songs in 10
days what were they doing obviously well
I don't know we won't even discuss while
they might have been doing
oh hey why you Amy we just don't go
there but um but what they were doing is
they're following some rules no blues
sorry tom no snow solo guitar I don't
know about Kevin but no solo guitar no
slide guitar and no base other than that
again who knows what they were doing but
they got an award winning great album
out in 10 days again a few simple rules
and simple rules and rules around
creativity are pretty interesting
because they actually force you to think
more one when we first started doing
this research we noticed that that that
better companies had this kind of simple
rules they didn't have no rules because
the people have no rules are often
having a really great time but there's
not shipping any products and not
selling anything and then there's and
that was like the the prototypical bad
West Coast company these Coast companies
tend to be way too many rules it was the
companies that found that middle spot
that in fact turned out to be the ones
that were pretty good ok timing rules
sometimes that timing rules are hard to
learn timing rules when to act what to
do are hard to do rhythms their heart
there tend to be harder to learn but it
wasn't too complex for nature
dragonflies actually migrated on on
timing rules so the green darter
dragonfly of the east coast margaret
south when there are two nights that are
below freezing they start their journey
and then they keep going on the journey
but any day that the wind is more than
15 miles an hour they stay put otherwise
they're headed south to Florida more
serious problem is insomnia roughly
twenty percent of the u.s. population
suffers from insomnia at least sometimes
during the year it turns out timing
rules are incredibly important to a
curing or at least helping insomnia
rules like go to bed when you're tired
our timing rule get up at the same time
every day more of a rhythm timing rule
and minimize the amount of time in bed
proven rules that help particularly the
elderly get a good night's sleep bring
it back to business think one of a lot
of people's favorite companies as Pixar
pixel when Pixar's started out they've
their first movie was the toy story or
Toy Story the problem with toy story was
that it took four years to create and
it's kind of hard to make a movie
business if you only do a movie every
four years and it's hard to get people
to actually want to work in your company
drilling doing a movie every four years
so they started to realize those maybe
we actually need to pick up the pace and
they started getting into this idea that
we're going to do one movie a year it's
actually not trivial to do one movie a
year when it takes you four years to
make a movie but they've got into that
rhythm and essentially started to
realize we do this in the first year
this is the second year this is the
third year this is the fourth year and
then you just kept flowing through and
so they created a pipeline and they
don't make it every year because every
so often they do get kind of a dud movie
and they just don't release it but
basically they're doing a movie a year
and they were leasing that movie at
Thanksgiving which is the biggest box
season time of the year for them movie a
year hit Thanksgiving that goes with
like a guy to another one that rules is
pre interesting rule story first graphic
second okay timing rules hard to learn
but worth your time to learn finally the
hardest rule of all to learn is one to
stop doing something when to call it
quits when to stay to go when is it when
is it time to move on this is a
critically important problem with your a
cricket particularly if you're female
cricket when have you found mr. right
when you find mr. right you'll have more
babies and you'll probably have a longer
life find mr. wrong we all know where
that goes so the question is what do you
do if you're a cricket how do you find
mr. right will you you you keep sort of
shopping crickets actually they come to
you and you pick the cricket that can
chirp at least three trips a second and
obviously better is better you know we
all know that if you find mr. right but
if you're stiff you spend about 24 hours
and mr. Wright still hasn't come your
way you lower your standards standards
which is as we all know from operations
research is the variable threshold
strategy also sometimes used at bars and
other places
so stopping rules stopping rules are
also I think important for investing
it's very easy to buy stocks very hard
to sell and our friend Steve Blank my
colleague Steve Blank I particularly all
know his rules I'm sure everybody in the
room knows his get out of the building
get out of the building talk to a
hundred people and you may not know this
one face to do it face-to-face what's
less known is his stopping rule and
stopping rules are after you've talked
to these hundred people and you've run
your business for a little while you ask
yourself for questions do customers see
this as a problem do customer will
customers pay for a solution to that
problem will they buy that solution from
us and can we create that solution if
the answer is yes yes yes yes keep going
you get a no it's time to do the
ever-popular pivot basically it's time
to stop okay so that was that was the
different kinds of rules and why am I
telling the rules they said as an
academic I love that there were just
different ones but as a real person that
you are perhaps more likely to be the
inside here is that as you're thinking
about what the heuristics are that start
to developing your business be sure you
figure out some hard ones be sure you
figure out a stopping rule you know when
is it time to leave this relationship
this business plan this whatever timing
rules and priority rules those are the
hard ones to pick up take your time to
learn those okay next part of the talk
why does simple rules work was as an
academic I actually care about this we
in academics we actually try to think
what's the underlying reason why things
are true so why is it the simple rules
seem to be pretty effective in people
like Mark Zuckerberg and Janet Yellen
use them and people like Steve Blank in
fact if you ever listen to Steve he is
like he's like always talking that way I
think that's actually one of the great
one of the chan insightful person why
does it always work they make better you
make better decisions you focus on
what's important your proxy for
information and gives discipline which
is all maybe a little abstract but
basically it lets you go faster and if
you're in entrepreneurship or if you
were in a big company
highly innovative you got to keep it
moving so they're there they lead faster
decisions so for example let's take
Warren Buffett world famous investor he
has a pretty simple rule always invest
in what you know or never invest in what
you don't know conversely very simple
rule makes for better decisions it turns
out that if you consider multiple
there's a study of picking jams of all
things if you give people a selection of
for jams they're likely to buy if you
give people a selection of 20 jams
they're not likely to buy it's too much
information it's too many alternatives
something simple works better if I give
you 10 things to do to be a better
student you'll do none of them if I give
you two rules I have at least some
chance you'll do something so Warren
Buffett simple rule the other thing
about about better decisions is that
rules often proxy for more information
so for example I mentioned you that you
know we partner with people have lasers
great screen machines that was a proxy
for something didn't really matter about
the machine it was a proxy for the fact
that people who had that machine were
likely to be innovative high quality
another another example as a company we
were looking at in some of our research
that was was expanding internationally
they had a rule always expand in
english-speaking countries turned out
the team was for brits most things of
speaking countries a brick you know
former British Empire the culture is
actually fairly similar the business
environment simpler and they tend to
have higher high GDP so the fact that
you are it has nothing really to do with
language in some sense it's a proxy for
something deeper finally I think better
decisions you get better decisions
because when you're busy when you're
tired when you're stressed is when you
when you can fall back on a roll and
that I think is the world that most
entrepreneurs most innovators most
executives and major corporations are in
there too busy and just like at the end
of the day is the time when you're going
to fall off the diet because you're
tired after the end of now at the end of
the day that Cabernet is calling you
it's when you're tired when you're
stressed out that you can fall back on a
roll so rules are also good because they
give you flexible opportunity capture
essentially rules let you scale that's
kind of the entrepreneur inside here if
you start figuring out what the rules
are you can scale a lot faster because
you're being efficient on the rule but
you're being flexible on exactly what
you do like the weinstein company
there's a certain kind of movie we want
flawed and sympathetic main character
within that we can pick a lot of
different movies flexible opportunity
capture well you may be never thought of
the Pope as an entrepreneur but actually
in 1540 the Jesuits were founded by
Ignatius of Loyola who is a Basque no
woman they turn out to be one of the
most entrepreneurial church
organizations known to man and they
actually start at a time when much of
the church is stuck with these really
boring rules like don't wear your Manas
no don't worry your slippers outside the
monastery only blood let four times a
year all these you know there's 11 order
that had seventy three chapters of rules
pages and pages and pages of rules in
contrast the Jesuits who by the way are
the educators of Bill Clinton Fidel
Castro Charles de Gaulle my brother and
actually a bunch of guys in and who
plays football at Stanford went to
jesuit schools had a few simple rules to
start out that that that order as the if
you will fifteenth century entrepreneurs
it was took maybe the quote Steve Blank
it was get out of the building as in get
out of the monastery walls in fact get
out of Europe and yet remember it's all
about saving souls so saving souls get
out of Europe get out of the monastery
with a little bit of a priority if you
have to choose for education what that
led the Jesuits to is all around the
world doing things it led one
particularly Jesuit to hang out with the
untouchables in India and rags
ministering to that community going over
to Japan hang out with the Shogun's
obviously upping his outfit to hang out
with the elite of Japan very flexible in
terms of what they did always about
saving souls whether it was lepers
prostitutes or whatever in helping
people but
a really broad mandate in which to do
that little more modern times how about
a little Yelp Yelp is another one
flexible capture of opportunities key
problem at Yelp is how do you get people
to review for free and keep doing it
because a lot of the yelp reviews or not
you know I mean everybody in this room
probably uses Yelp how many of you
review for a Yelp yeah like two that's
the problem is it's like two and you
know I IL pat I don't review either and
so the question is how do you get people
to review and get jazzed about it how do
you keep them reviewing and so they and
and Yelp has got some kind of
interesting motivational techniques
which maybe is for another time but the
point is it's enabled Yelp to be around
the world to be in taco stands to avea
and other elite restaurants plenty them
kind of do whatever they want with
reviewers are all of all stripes so the
point is it let Yelp go to lots of
cities lots of restaurants lots of
kinder reviewers all within a few simple
rules then finally superior coordination
is something that rules get you give you
an example shared economy is all about
coordination of large numbers of people
doing something zipcar great example of
how do you coordinate however many
customers zipcar has hundreds hundreds
of thousands some crazy number of people
how do they start out at least before
they were before they were bought by
Avis couple simple rules around
coordinating behavior and why does it
work by the way for coordinating
behavior because when you keep just a
small handful of rules or a handful of
precepts people can remember it people
can communicate it and you can enforce
it zipcar what are the what are the
things you had to do return the car on
time report damage folk the gas tank
keep pets and carriers don't smoke
pretty simple set of things that
coordinated hundreds of thousands of
people doing things true of wikipedia at
least the one Wikipedia started
wikipedia started with a couple of rules
neutral so that was facts not opinions
you always have to have a source and
then their third rule which I I told you
love is and don't follow any other rules
they of course have changed that if
you've been to Wikipedia lately but if
you think about what Wikipedia
accomplished in terms of crowdsourcing
encyclopedia and the knowledge of the
world it's an incredible it's an
incredible achievement and most of that
growth was when they had simple rules
how about superior coordination from
Janet Yellen Janet Yellen Federal
Reserve chair Janet Yellen has a hard
job the US economy is not a simple
economy is it a lot going on in the US
economy and part of her job is
communicating what the feds going to do
so that to the business people and
investors have a sense of where the
economy is going and have the confidence
to invest what does she do she has a
rule called mind the gap and the gap
refers to the difference between the
ideal unemployment rate in the actual
employment rate and refers to the ideal
inflation rate and what's the
intolerable inflation rate and she's
monitoring those two essentially those
two gaps and setting interest rates she
and the Board of Governors obviously but
what that's doing is not only does it
appear to be pretty good monetary policy
it also is giving people an
understanding people in the investment
community in the business community the
sense of what's going on with interest
rates so they can plan however they want
to plan so it's the it's not just that
there are good rules it's that she's
able to communicate a very difficult set
of choices in fact in a very simple way
finally as we're kind of getting to the
end here gone through water simple rules
how do you create them what are the
kinds why do they work they work because
they make decisions faster they let you
scale they let coordinate large groups
of people finally how do you update it
turns out that when you first think
about heuristics rules of thumb whatever
you want to call these they're usually
not all that great in fact the example
I'm going to use is is the Stanford
football team for those of you who are
Stanford football fans you do recall the
one and eleven sivan's not so long ago
and then how much maybe you've blocked
that out at this point and you're now
just remembering the Rose Bowls and
these orange bowls and the pac-12 titles
but there are those of us who remember
the days what actually was good because
you could always get a seat but the
story i really want to tell is the story
of shannon Turley who's the strength
coach at the Stanford football team he
starts out Shannon's story starts out
he's the University of West Virginia and
he wants to be a strength coach and so
he hangs out at the football in the
football locker room and he learns about
how to do bench presses and squats and
the power of a motivational t-shirt that
says personal record on it but then he
moves on and he starts coaching in
professional baseball the minor leagues
with the Kansas City Royals well it
turns out the Kansas City Royals are not
buying the football strength program
they're saying and why should i do a
bench press and why should I squat I'm a
pitcher so he has to start justifying
why his stuff should work and make a bit
make somebody a better picture for
example then he moves on and he's then a
graduate assistant university missouri
and he's keys the strength training
coach of women's volleyball I don't want
to speak for all women but like bench
press is not real interesting to me I'm
barely even know what one is and I don't
think I want one um but women's but
unless women's volleyball players do
have to work out and you have to be in
shape and what they need to be able to
do is they need to be able to jump and
they need footwork and so what's
shannons started it was developed okay
that's really what these women need they
don't need to bench press they need to
be able to jump and they need to be able
to to move their feet fast as he's doing
this he's starting to reflect on what
does it really mean to us to be a
strength coach so then he gets to
Stanford and he's actually brought here
by Jim Harbaugh they worked together in
San Diego Jim brought him here and he
starts really now now he's in charge of
his own football team and what he does
is he focuses on something that pretty
much no other strength coach is focusing
on it's not about being stronger that's
not the goal it's about reducing
injuries that what we want they hit what
Shannon realized was you want your best
players on the field they are the ones
who play the most they're the ones who
get hurt you don't want injuries and
particularly if your school like
Stanford where you have a very thin team
because there are not that many players
who can play a leap
all and and also passed courses at
Stanford so it's a very thin team you
don't want those apart from the the
moral aspect if you don't want people to
get hurt there is the strategic aspect
of you don't want your team hurt and so
what his rules started to be much more
about than really any other straights
coach were about injury prevention
injury prevention a lot of a lot of his
rules around stretching and he has a
couple rules around basically exercising
in ways that is relevant to your
position and as Shannon says bench
brantley seems sort of pointless because
once you're because you do it on your
back because once you're on your back
you've lost in football so why would you
practice that so he's into so is he has
a couple rules around strength training
focused on particularly on flexibility
because I keeps you from getting hurt a
couple things focused on injury
prevention a couple things focused on
functionally relevant to your position
and by the way apart from the Stanford
football team having a better record
which I think just some extent is due to
their strength training has reduced
injuries by eighty-seven percent so we
also have a healthier team with guys who
can go on with their lives and not be
cripples improving the rules let's get
back to something a little more
entrepreneurial how about Airbnb Airbnb
starts in San Francisco as I'm sure many
of you know with some guys trying to
earn extra money by renting out space in
their apartment on an air mattress and
giving them a bagel in the morning seems
like a great idea they do it at a
conference that's coming to San
Francisco they get a lot of people a lot
of people buying in so they say well you
know it's all about the conferences and
by the way it's probably it's probably
kids are trying to save money they go to
South by Southwest they get like three
people want the comment want their
service they try the Democratic and
Republican conventions a little more
action but after the conventions are
over Airbnb who so what do they do they
join y combinator they're lucky enough
to get into y combinator and what the
story of y combinator is this by the way
the stanford football story was around
what Shannon did
self reflect on what he was learning in
each of the sports that he coached what
the what the Airbnb story is about is
not only self-reflection but learning in
a variety of ways because at the end of
the day y combinator and companies like
that our accelerators of learning it's
about how do you learn faster and the
story of y combinator is multi team Ulta
Pelini for example there's the Tuesday
night dinner where you listen to some
luminary talk about his or her
experience so you have a cover role
model of what to do during the pre and
post time of that dinner you're talking
with other entrepreneurs about their
experiences so you're vicariously
learning about what they're learning in
their businesses they're starting up so
you're learning very curiously about
them they're also asking new questions
about what you're doing and you're
having to articulate what you do so
you're learning from other people your
peers as well as from the luminary
that's the Tuesday night dinner they
also have special coaching by Y
Combinator personnel experienced
entrepreneurs or exist experienced
coaches for example for the air B&B guys
one of they learned some really valuable
pieces of advice from Paul Graham one of
the founders very of Y Combinator he
told them having a hundred customers
love you is way more important than a
thousand customers liking you so that
sort of set us a sense of okay that's
the kind of service we have to deliver
their second piece of advice was get out
of Mountain View and go to New York City
I mean it's not going to take off in
mountain view it's going to take off in
New York or cities like New York so they
go to New York every week they're going
to New York so that's the third part of
the story get the advice from an expert
they go to New York and it's on the
ground there doing experiments for
example through professional photos work
they're doing trial and error learning
with hey well apartment managers want to
be want to be doing this for us so
during trial and error experiments
observation learning in a variety of
ways after their y combinator experience
they start to see what's really going on
for them forget the conference's is
about international destination cities
and more importantly it's about the
bottleneck for them as hosts you get the
hosts right and business will happen and
that's what they realized with the
combination of the Tuesday dinners
expert advice on the ground seeing
people it's about the hosts and in
particularly developed some ideas around
how do you recruit a host it's about a
certain kind of party we're friends
bring friends and then it's also about
training hosts but it's not giving the
hosts zillion things to learn it's about
a couple things like clean sheets fresh
soap I mean who wants to go to
somebody's house with old soap it's
about the soap and about professional
photography but really only a couple
things to remember fresh so clean sheets
professional photos and so the point is
that that many successful entrepreneurs
many successful business people on
established corporations improve their
initial rules making them more strategic
by multiple ways of learning finally
talked about changing the rules
sometimes it's just improving the rules
you've got making the more strategic
sometimes you got to break the rules let
that say too much about California
drought because I'm not seeing too many
gardeners in the audience so I won't go
dwell on gardening perhaps you but maybe
nobody else let's just say that the
California drought has rocked the world
of gardeners because all the rules are
different you don't plant in the spring
anymore you plan on the fall you don't
worry about the flowers you look at the
leaves and the textures you don't worry
about good soil because native plants
like lousy soil you don't worry about
summer watering because the watering
matters in April it's a whole different
set of rules that have rocked the world
of gardeners and probably erupt and so
rather than responding to the drought by
the two seas concrete and cactus great
gardeners are in fact rewriting the
rules finally rewriting the rules well
cheers didn't exactly rewrite the rules
but house of cards did house of cards
broke every rule that cheers was the
prototype for cheers was one of the
original most successful sitcoms
television shows of all time 40 million
Americans watched the last episode of
cheers
that's that's more than anything you can
think of that people would watch 40
million people watching the end of
cheers Cheers focused on writing cheers
had fabulous writers and they wrote
likeable characters who appeared every
week who told a story in a half an hour
so you had Sam and Diane and the various
characters of Tears y'all know cheers
yeah everybody knows cheers everybody
knows you where everybody knows your
name it's the other tagline so what
happens after cheers by the way cheers
is now the formula of the Big Bang
Theory Two and a Half Men as well as
dramas like Grey's Anatomy they are all
following the cheers formula what about
house of cards what about Netflix well
think of the strategic problem netflix
has your DVD business is dying it's
going to streaming you don't have any
content how are you going to create
content that stands out and so what
Netflix does is basically break all the
rules of television first of all they do
to have great writing and that wasn't
that path breaking because because shows
like The Sopranos and homeland were also
they're also great writing the wire edgy
great writing but they broke but they
nonetheless had that kind of writing
they broke those cheers rules about
likable I mean who likes those too you
know nobody who mean they're not rude
well they're starting to get endearing
but they're not real likable it isn't
this cast of characters that you see
every week if they are their characters
aren't explored and so forth so first
point Netflix breaks the television
rules and copies more the soprano tech
rules but where's the real break out the
real breakout is they not only do they
break writing rules they go to a new
bottle neck and that's directing in
particular David Fincher becomes on as
their director David Fincher did the
social network girl with the dragon
tattoo Benjamin buttons long string of
hits top notch Hollywood director he
becomes the lead director he then brings
in other lead directors like the
director of Desperate Housewives the
death and the director of The Sopranos
now on coulter
and the those directors come in in each
of those directors you have to do two
episodes they have to be sequential you
have to do that but you can hire your
own daily people for example so you
still have to use Kevin space you can't
switch outs Kevin Spacey but if you have
a person that's going to only be in your
two episode you can hire that person if
you want to the other thing you're you
were recommended that you should use a
stationary camera because you get a more
cinematic quality fact one of the really
striking features of house of cards is
the cinematic visual quality of the show
and that's largely because of the kind
of directors who direct that and the
stationary camera work within that a
top-notch director can do whatever he or
she wants as long as you do two episodes
all you have to have a 20-day shoot 20
days shoot two episodes please use a
cinematic camera is stationary camera
but you don't have to after that do what
you want to do and what you get is a
show and that is actually on maybe
because we're getting toy Santa time I'm
just say one last thing that they did
they broke programming rules by the
binge-watching and they also broke
hiring rules by essentially a-list
director a list actors and the the
creator of of the show is not quite a
list yet but he's been a nominated for
Academy Award to a top-notch writer what
are they doing I maybe we'd say one last
thing about them is they they with
ticularly with the binge-watching and
the other thing they do which is a
programming change the binge allowing
binge watching and buying two years of
house of cards sight unseen that was
there is nobody in television who does
that why didn't Alexa why could Netflix
do that because they knew from they
divvy business they knew you would like
house of cards because you before you
knew you'd like house of cards you knew
Netflix subscribers watch the British
television version and they knew that
Netflix subscribers likes like Kevin
Spacey so they exploited their data
analytics to create a rock rock the
industry rule around programming and the
purchase of programming because of their
their their characteristics that they
had so finally just to wrap up I think I
got a little long long winded there but
let me
just wrap up about what simple rules are
a handful unique to you on something
specific how do you get them you have an
objective you find your body like you
create the rules the kinds of rules pay
attention to the stopping and timing
rules why do they work they make you
faster than that you scale to let you
coordinate and then finally changing the
rules by using basic learning techniques
like self-reflection experiential
learning and trial and error so let me
just close with one of the ultimate
innovators Leonardo da Vinci not
Leonardo DiCaprio simplicity is the
ultimate sophistication so thanks a lot
no time for questions and cost anybody
yes what were your way one of my rules
call Danielle no III Danielle who's our
expert graphics designer at st BP
created the slides and what I wanted I
tried to have the rule was around mixing
entrepreneurial companies with things
you weren't expecting that was my role
was to mix up mix up the content
internet dating ah you got to buy the
book oh no i'll give you one tip on in
your debt dating the most the most
successful greeting on internet email is
how's it going so try that everybody
okay any other questions yeah Toby look
at this framework and then you start to
look at these dancer companies that
you've worked with their pattern of one
or two things that this thing that you
see them making consistently yeah they
don't take the time to crystallize what
they're doing they just keep they just
keep doing doing doing they never step
back self-reflect test what's going on
here that's probably the biggest one
anybody else yes if you talk about any
rules you have is an engine rules for
what being an engineer rule for being an
engineer um that's a good question i i i
am an engineer mechanical engineering
computer science but i haven't been an
engineer in a long time but i knew no
rules about being a go first of all one
of our points is actually your rules are
your rules so you know another kind of
engineer might have a totally different
rule but but one thing to watch out for
i think that's a really sort of basic
career advice is be sure you've got a
really good first boss your immediate
boss is good because he or she will then
connect you to the rest of the company
well
just cuz you're not your hair doesn't
mean you can't be a humanist as well you
can't be human as well I maybe that's
maybe that's Leonardo yes as well all
right anything else anybody or we got
but yes I just have a kind of a simple /
engine is talking movies and then to
know then you should just stop doing it
but my question is how do you kind of
factor in like emotional kind of like
how do you factor in emotion expecting
like see ya well that is actually taking
the emotions that's actually one of the
reasons why the rules work because it's
very hard to say goodbye to an old
friend named a bad business idea and so
that's actually what a water rule does
like you're a bad stock or dare I say a
bad relationship it's when you have the
rule that it actually takes the emotion
out of it and you sort of in the
abstract say you know I know that's not
working I know I should quit and get
over the emotion if you will yes huh we
see large companies like Disney with
huge handbooks of roles literally how do
you scale backwards towards simple rules
once you've accumulated a lot more
regulation um actually Netflix is an
interesting example of that nay I mean I
don't think they ever had the scale of
rule said that the Disney had but they
used to have rules around their travel
policies you know you can expense this
you can't expense that yadda yadda yadda
they just they basically just got rid of
it around travel because they expensive
because they said it's taking our people
a lot of time to fill all this stuff out
they don't remember the rules anyway so
they're probably not following them they
just went to some rule I think it was
something around if you wouldn't pay for
it yourself don't make us pay for it too
uh so I think it's focusing on what's
the problem I mean you can't it's kind
of like health care you know you're not
going to fix health care in one bill you
know you gotta chip away at parts of it
so if it's what's the particular problem
is it you know expense resistors just
driving everybody crazy is it
powerpoints it meanings is it something
more substantive around
product innovation but picking picking
your spot and then stripping it away and
in getting the people what we've seen
work is getting the people who actually
have to use the rules develop the rules
try the rules out and come up with it
yes institutions like the IRS to
simplify the rules other countries have
done so like small ones like Estonia or
Russia has no 10-percent of your income
that's it and you don't have a how do we
do that oh this is interesting and
income taxes because the the rate of
compliance and paying your taxes is
inversely correlated with the size of
your tax code so the bigger your tax
code the less people pay and the more
they cheat perhaps in purpose perhaps
not how do you get that one of the
problems with government and neither
Republican or Democrat here but is that
there are too many special interests
that actually like the complexity in the
tax code whether it's your favorite
accountant or whether it's your oil and
gas lobby or your soybean growing farmer
or whoever it is it's the special entry
at least am i sounding like I don't know
do I sound like Rand Paul or something
actually I'm doing a radio interview
tomorrow on the rand paul channel
speaking of but i think the problem is
you have too many people for whom
complexity is payday and so that's a a
would be a lot better if we all paid ten
percent or whatever the percent is but
they're too many interests which i think
is what also happened with health care
not that health care was ever gonna be
simple but too many people are happy the
way it is thanks everybody for coming
you